cam thanks for joining us let's start
with colin kaepernick on the field what
did you see from Kaepernick last night
well thanks for having me Dan he played
a lot better than we saw the last game
last Friday night against packers I only
played a quarter and it was kind of
throw some state of vintage Kaepernick
where he was able to you know get the
passes on target and take off running
the way everybody see him and you try to
keep in mind that this is the fourth
exhibition against bunch of last
stringers and hey you need to variety
thrust himself back into the
conversation that he is definitely not a
South quarterback and if the 49ers you
know neither number two he's the guy
because right now still probably Blaine
Gabbert starting quarterback for that
team and I thought that with Kaepernick
playing majority of the game last night
that meant that Blaine Gabbert starts in
week one but it feels like it's a little
tenuous that situation that Gabbert can
play himself out of that role quickly
your thoughts on that yeah I think I
think they wanted Blaine to you know
really secure the job and he did
everything for the most part throughout
the exhibition season in training camp
you reallys acted a lot like the
starting quarterback should be he hadn't
been sensational and I don't know if
they really wanted him to I don't like
Chip Kelly I'm go to the playbook for
him but at the same time Kaepernick's
been dealing with a sore shoulder
through camp and obviously there's been
a little bit of a controversy that's
lauded for the last week and he handled
that that aspect of it well if a twist
last night tale all right tell me about
pregame first book with Kaepernick then
we'll talk about postgame pretty aim it
was a pretty dramatic scene because as
about yet about 200 servicemen on the
field here in San Diego on Military
Appreciation Night in it that are
unfurling the flag Kaepernick went down
on a knee and he didn't do it alone he
let down with Eric Reid one of their one
of her team leaders and cryptic and he
is well with him and then to
Kaepernick's left standing up was Nate
boy or the green beret and he's a long
snapper that played briefly with the
Seahawk class from camp and audition for
Atlanta class
year and when the anthem is over
obviously everybody now is aware that
Kaepernick is protesting the anthem and
hugs from several fortinet her teammates
and you know during the game there are a
couple other moments where you know that
that protest was put to the test because
I think in the second quarter they asked
all the veterans to stand up in the
crowd and everybody applauded and
recognize them and Kaepernick stood
there and applauded them too and then
after the third quarter god Bless
America was saying and and Kaepernick
was standing at attention in the
plotting just like everybody else so it
was quite a fan throughout the night how
was the postgame seen you know I don't
know people seeing us at a Colin
Kaepernick I've covered him for six
years I have never seen him you know
speak so self-assured assuredly and
confident exactly I hit it hit her the
same way to Kim I was like I i
interviewed Kaepernick when they were
going to the Super Bowl and he was not
very forthcoming but with this I mean
he's up there and ready to talk he can't
seem to say enough I mean sunday he
spoke with us at his locker for about 20
minutes and then last night at the game
same thing pretty much you feel that
every question he didn't back down
whatsoever he stated this case at police
are murdering innocent people oppressed
minorities that he the police brutality
something that needs to be addressed
that again that he's not trying to
disrespect the US military that he's
very respectful of that and he trying to
create a dialogue you know for racial
racial justice and last night he also
brought up that he's going to try to do
some more actions in terms of you're
gonna be donated is the first million
dollars he makes a share and get into
the communities to try to help everybody
because he says they need help yeah it
almost feels like he like this is so
important to him that would be my only
concern if I'm Chip Kelly what is most
important to you you know because as a
coach he's trying to win it's his first
year there I need to know where your
priorities are if I'm going to look at
you as a starter on this team how would
Kaepernick answer that
hey that's a great question because it
really does seem like he's moonlighting
and quarterbacking to think he's trying
to quarterback the 49ers and now he's
trying to quarterback the social
movement that that is showing signs of
catching on where the CL Seahawks Jeremy
Lane he sat down during the national
anthem other guys are showing signs at
that Kaepernick's not alone in this I
think Chip Kelly it would be different
than a few words the starting
quarterback right now she's not the
starting quarterback yeah he hasn't
played enough I think this team still is
Blaine Gabbert's team and that's why you
know Chip Kelly kept an open mind about
it trying to get pond you know equal
wrapped and they've played about
basically same amount of time now the
exhibition season and at the same time
there's still a lot of friction I
believe between Kaepernick and the 49ers
front office so ultimately the call and
whether Kaepernick's on the team was no
fallen print Balki's hands the general
manager and I after last night after he
showed that he can still play
quarterback they can't get rid of them
camp thanks for getting up early we
appreciate it thanks for joining us
thank their that's cam Inman it covers
the Niners for the San Jose Mercury News
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience